This would be an awesome
story to tell our kids.
"I met your dad
in a social experiment."
"I'm sorry. What, Mum?"
Welcome to Love Is Blind!
I'm here because
I'm looking for the one.
I haven't found someone
that appreciates my love
as much
as I appreciate theirs.
That's why I'm here.
I'm ready for marriage,
but I've never felt
true love in my life.
I don't think I ever said
to anyone "I love you",
except my mum.
Looking forward
to what potentially could be
discovered in these pods.
The pods are
officially open.
-Open!
-Here we go!
Guys, there'll be
no devices.
Zero distractions.
The only time you guys
are gonna interact
are in the private pods.
I'm putting my hand on
the wall. Can you see me?
-No, I can't.
-Are you as nervous as I am?
-Oh, my God.
-Hello?
Welcome to my pod.
-I work in real estate.
-Do you sell a lot?
'Cause I feel like you have
to be somewhat attractive
to sell a lot.
I love buying clothes
for girls.
Now, what's your size?
What the fuck?
-You're my number one, so…
-Really?
You were my number one too.
Ooh, look at that.
OK, never have I ever
had sex in a public place.
I just wanna be by you.
I know.
Will you marry me?
It's so crazy to see
all the couples together.
Damn.
Everyone's so attractive.
-This is…
-It's great.
Yeah.
We were gone
for almost three weeks.
I'm like trying to bury
under a mountain of emails.
Back to reality.
-That was pathetic.
-That was not good.
-Can I do that again?
-Yeah, you better.
Now is the time to decide…
…if love is truly blind.
We did it. We're married.
You're my husband.
Oh, God. Oh, God. Oh, God.